-The reality is, even though
we do this every night,
we don´t always have time
to cover all of the recent news.
So here with a recap is one
of our writers, Amber Ruffin,
in a segment we call
"Amber Says What."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, you guys!
Things have been crazy!
Okay. First of all,
a billion people
have been accused
of sexual harassment.
And folks are, like, "What?!"
But women are, like, "What?"
[ Laughter ]
Then, Blake Shelton
was named Sexiest Man Alive,
but I was like, "What..."
[ Laughter ]
"...happened to Idris Elba.
Is he okay?"
[ Laughter ]
And they were like,
"Yeah, we just think
Blake Shelton
is the sexiest man alive."
But I was like, "What?!"
You know who the sexiest
man alive actually is?
model and actor Kofi Siriboe.
Whoo!
He is so hot that, if
a white girl brought him home
to meet her parents,
they would be like, "Ooh."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then, Australia voted
to legalize gay marriage.
And I was like, "What?
They didn´t already have it?"
[ Laughter ]
Gay marriage
was too weird for you,
but you let these
whatchamacallits
run around everywhere?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then, the Keystone
pipeline burst,
and I had so many whats.
First of all, what did you think
was going to happen?
Secondly, what did you think
all those protests were about?
And lastly, what do you need
all that oil for?
Is it for your oily children?
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Silky smooth.
Now, then, at the AMAs,
everybody said Pink made a face
at Christina Aguilera,
as she was singing a tribute
to Whitney Houston,
and I was like, "What?
That´s not like Pink."
And Pink was like, "What?!
I didn´t do that."
That´s just people trying
to start drama between women.
And I was like, "Amen!"
Then --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, yeah.
I felt the same way!
Then, I watched the clip.
-♫ You-ooh-ooh,
hoo-ooh-ooh-ooh ♫
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughing ]
It was like, "Wh-a-a-a-at?!"
Ooh.
I love her, though.
Then, Serena Williams
had a spectacular wedding.
Whoo! I saw those pictures,
and I was like, "What?
I cannot handle
how beautiful this is."
And then I was like,
"There had better not be
a photo of them
and their adorable baby."
Wh-a-a-at?!
[ Laughter ]
Then, I was like,
"There had better not be
a big family photo
that shows how much
they all love each other."
Wh-a-a-at?!
[ Laughter ]
Then, I was like,
"Well, as long as there´s
not a photo of Beyoncé
at the wedding."
Wh-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-at?!
[ Glass cracks ]
This has been
"Amber Says What."
[ Cheers and applause ]